one of the guys who's playing for the
47% who don't seem to like the
government at all is is Rand Paul and he
gave a speech at Liberty University this
is Jerry Falwell 's College I suppose
and he gave a speech on eugenics now
first off apparently he stole a lot of
the speech from the movie Gattaca on
Wikipedia he like lifted it I don't know
I don't want to get into that I want to
talk about eugenics specifically alright
so let's let's take a look at what Rand
Paul said in your lifetime much of your
potential or lack thereof can be known
simply by swabbing the inside of your
cheek are we prepared to select out the
imperfect among us now eugenics and kara
I'm gonna let you give a slightly more
scientific explanation than I am
eugenics basically is the system by
which people can sort of select out the
less desirable sort of so if let's say
two obese people were mating and we
didn't want to have obese people mate
you would stop them from mating to get
rid of obesity which sort of maybe
sounds good but really is a very
slippery slope clean that up no ok I'm
not by any means a eugenics expert but
but you know my background is in biology
and psychology and I think you know
genex as a concept is something that it
can be approached historically
sociologically biologically whatever so
I think obviously a popular example is
when we look back to to Hitler's Germany
right and so we think about the idea of
Hitler wanted to have a pure race and so
he wanted to eliminate certain people
from from the population that he felt
dirtied up the race and I think that
this is the most extreme and most
disgusting example of eugenics and I
think that that's kind of what that name
makes people think about when they hear
that right and I think it's an easy
stick scare tactic right right for Rand
Paul to use and he wanted to so Hitler
wanted to do it to breed blond-haired
blue-eyed people basically and he wanted
to do it through breeding but also but
technology has changed now we're now it
can be done through science and they can
you know change your eye color
it's all still breeding so so basically
what he's trying to say is that if we
can use any sort of kind of genetic test
to figure out if somebody has an illness
in utero that's going to prevent them
from leading a full and healthy life for
example that it's it's immoral to
terminate that pregnancy and I think a
lot of people would disagree with that I
think a lot of people you know a woman
finds out that she is carrying a child
with a trisomy you know with Down
syndrome with some sort of issue that
would cause that child to live a life in
horrible pain or with some sort of issue
that would cause that child
to you know to not be able to live at
all to not survive the birthing process
or much after the birthing process many
people would say that's completely a
valid reason to terminate the pregnancy
so I think that he's taking you know
he's making a huge slippery slope
argument and and he's making a very
extreme in order to rally the true for
Cucinelli like to be able to support
cuccinelli there in Virginia right and
again he's doing this at Liberty
University which obviously is a
Christian College so he's playing to the
religious base I get all that again it's
that that intellectual dishonesty and
and self confliction that goes not
confliction yeah because he's a big guy
Rand yeah hollower and this is the very
sort of program that she would have been
all for Oh completely that's totally
valid in her mind and you know Mike can
you just explain for people that don't
get why that why she would be well that
I was in favor of a full meritocracy
that whatever works is good and whoever
has the money deserves the money and
whoever is succeeding is and it's sort
of a social Darwinism never mind the
fact that by the end of her life she was
broke and living off of government
assistance because once she needed it it
was just fine I know I feel that I'm
Randa as a writer and as a philosopher
came up with very simple very clear
answers to questions that by all rights
should trouble us deeply throughout our
lives the last thing we should find for
them is simple clear answers and when
Rand Paul then says eugenics is this
horrible thing at a Christian University
Bo
that in many ways the Catholic Church
itself has been running the
longest-running eugenics project in
history starting in the Dark Age well
before the Dark Ages when they started
pulling the most intellectually capable
members of society out making them
celibate bringing them into the church
and educating them while encouraging
those who weren't worthy of that
education to reproduce like bunny
rabbits thereby creating a you know
generation after generation after
generation of less capable critical
thinkers over now what centuries
unfortunately that strategy doesn't work
because as we all know evolution occurs
in a more Darwinian fashion it doesn't
colonel the marquee in fashion right and
you can't pass on intelligence genes
it's just there's no evidence to support
the fact that intelligent people are
going to systematically breed more
intelligent on rank just because of
their genetic makeup
I mean oftentimes if you're raised by
bright parents who who you know want to
foster intellectual curiosity and you
you're more likely to to become an
intellectual individual as it stands but
there's there's really no evidence to
support the fact that when smart people
breed they make smart babies and when
dumb people bring it they make dumb baby
is there really no evidence of that
because I mean totally shakes the
foundation of myself you need a minute
complicated issue to approach
biologically and psychologically but
fundamentally I think the point that
you're making that Rand Paul based on
his own kind of personal philosophy
right seems like he would be a huge
supporter of you yes this is again a
political move there has nothing to do
with what he actually thinks yeah it has
everything to do with trying to
manipulate a group of people that have
strong religious values into voting a
certain way okay I totally read this is
against his political ethos and yet he's
doing it obviously and this goes to what
we were talking about a second ago about
the Tea Party and the religious right
whatever you have to say to get the
votes yes also it within his philosophic
so all right so removing the religious
part of this for a sec
we can hire you that if we're Liberty
can we're kind of let's see if we can do
it here just for a second of the
religious part for a second isn't this
eugenics actually good but isn't this
the next step in human evolution that we
will systematically remove the things
that are bad about us that are
genetically wrong with us and that we
will it's as deep it's a deep moral
issue that I think regardless of whether
or not you you subscribe to any sort of
religious denomination can still be a
difficult one to swallow and I think
it's because it's a very nuanced
situation we already are not we're more
subject to what we would call artificial
selection right a natural selection
right we make decisions based on who
we're gonna make that are outside of
kind of random natural decisions right
so we're doing it on a day to day basis
actually the same way that we breed our
dogs in order to have very specific
traits that was told I'm not allowed to
breed with my dog but when you breed two
dogs together what you end up is a bunch
of different breeds of dog who look so
different from a Chihuahua to a Great
Dane and they're all the same species
right and you see that in some respects
with in humankind right you see mating
based on all sorts of different reasons
maybe based on looks maybe based on
intelligence based on you know kindness
whatever the case may be so we already
make decisions about how we're going to
procreate and where we're fundamentally
in charge of those decisions so on the
light end you might want to call that
eugenics I don't know on the heavy end
trying to wipe out certain people
because we disagree with them
philosophically because we disagree with
them politically I think I'm an atheist
I don't I don't subscribe to a religion
at all and I'm very much against
organized religion but that to me is
fundamentally immoral right because you
could you could eliminate if they found
the gay gene this is what everyone says
they'll find the gay gene and then
they'll get rid of gay there's another
reason too to kind of have an in-group
out-group status and to to push a hate
agenda so I think you've got to find
that middle ground where we're talking
about somebody who's not a person yet
right you're talking about an embryo
and that embryo has such heavily such
heavy genetic damage that it's going to
create a life that potentially couldn't
live on its own or that would be in such
pain and would struggle so much that the
mother because it is still her person
right as long as that is still an embryo
inside of her it's a it's a human rights
issue and she has the right to terminate
that pregnancy I think that's a
completely different issue than you Jim
yeah you just brought us so much good
stuff we're going to do another second
but first of all for the record let me
also say that that I am also an atheist
I am so completely an atheist that when
people tell me they believe in God
I don't believe them yeah I think we get
into trouble when we talk about is this
good or bad
that we can do it because I think
science at its in in its purest form is
neither good nor bad it is neutral the
question is how new discoveries and new
abilities are then applied and you draw
the line at what a life be in so much
pain or so in care will have taken care
of itself my mind would be will it be
forced to live with my parents but there
you know there are all sorts of
different lines that can be drawn and
these are very individual decisions and
very individual choices and they they
lie with the woman in question they lied
to some degree with the man in question
if there's an agreement as to who's
going to wind up raising this I mean
fundamentally what what you're saying
about about science I do think that
there is some morality wrapped up into
science because science fundamentally is
done by people and they have agendas
before they set out to do their science
but ultimately I think that regulation
is to be left to the regulators and I
think that a voting public needs to be
choosing how we regulate and if that's
what you need true democracy where the
voting public is making the decision not
moneyed interests that are then chosen
by the voting public to represent the
supposedly voting public's interest and
in fact is right and we and we keep our
voting public so dumb that they're not
informed will be well enough to make the
right decisions on this kind of stuff
hey guys the Ruben
it's brought to you by Koopa calm they
have up to 75% off pet treats choose
toys and more and if you use code RR you
get another 20% that's a lot of
percentage right there I can't do that
kind of math the link is right down
below
Cooper comm code RR